[Musique]
bonsoir comme tous les lundis nous
sommes en direct sur lcp public sénat
avec le figaro pour audition publique
une heure de direct avec anne invité
principal et ce soir c'est bruno
retailleau bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
président du groupe est républicain au
sénat c'est principal groupe au sénat et
vous êtes sénateur de vendée
merci d'être sur ce gâteau alors on a
beaucoup de choses à dire en ce
lendemain des municipales avec vous on
va un peu revenir sur les municipales
mais ça passe tellement vite que ça
paraît déjà loin les municipales parce
qu'on va parler déjà des régionales des
sénatoriales par exemple entre autres on
va parler aussi de la sphère fillon tout
à l'heure on va parler du plan de
relance toutes ces choses là notamment
avec brigitte boucher était mme tran huy
les chaînes parlementaires qui seront là
sur le plateau tout à l'heure et puis
avec deux parlementaires david assouline
sénateur ps de paris est r weber ville
porte parole des députés la république
en marche et député des côtes d'armor
qui vous parlerons de tout cela et pour
conclure
yves thréard du figaro qui nous
rassemblera tout ce qui s'est dit au
cours de l'émission et tu auras ces
questions à lui notamment alors lui
parlera déjà la présentielle 2022 c'est
dire si ça va très vite quand même
l'actualité politique
première question d'actualité du jour le
tribunal correctionnel de paris a rendu
sa décision dans la sphère fillon cinq
ans de prison de prison dont deux ferme
contre l'ancien premier ministre
ancien candidat à la présidentielle
375000 euros damende dix ans
d'inéligibilité
ses avocats vont faire appel quoi qu'il
en soit vous dites vous la justice doit
passer
non d'abord je voudrais redire à
françois fillon mon soutien dans une
période qui est extrêmement difficiles
je les ai eus au téléphone dans l'après
midi l'île aux édiles et donc quel état
d'esprit
écoutez je crois qu'il est un homme
solide mais croyez moi il est
profondément touché comment ne peut-on
pas l'être cette peine pour que les
téléspectateurs comprennent bien cinq
ans avec sursis
je vais vous donner deux exemples c'est
par exemple une femme qui a laissé
mourir son enfant de sept mois c'est par
exemple un homme qui a défiguré à coups
de couteau qui a des visages et sa
victime en la filmant pour ensuite la
diffuser
c'est ce visage défiguré sur les réseaux
sociaux cinq ans c'est très très lourd
qu'est ce que voulait dire qu'en fait
cette comparaison
je veux dire c'est elle est extrêmement
sévère est ce qu'il avait dit aux
étudiants c'est une décision pour des
lacs ans la révélation
les révélations café madame houle est
ici à l'assemblée nationale devant une
commission d' enquête sur l'indépendance
de la justice et donc sous serment
nous savons depuis ces derniers jours
que l a fait l'objet de pression de sa
hiérarchie
elle a dit elle même qu'on ne pouvait
que se posaient des questions et l'a
souligné des ingérences quasiment
quotidiennes elle a indiqué finalement
que sa hiérarchie a voulu accélérer les
poursuites contre françois fillon parce
que en réalité il fallait le mettre en
examen
très vite il avait lui-même sans doute
imprudemment déclaré qu' il ne
retirerait sa candidature à l'élection
présidentielle qu'à la condition d'être
mise en examen devant donc il fallait
que le calendrier judiciaire puisse
briser cette candidature à la
présidentielle
c'est proprement stupéfiant c'est
absolument inédit or ces révélations
auraient dû être prises en compte les
avocats françois fillon avait demandé
que les débats soient ré ouvert il ya je
crois le jugement fait 168 pages 168
pages
il n'y a aucune mention aucune mention
de cette demande de réouverture des
débats qui tend d'ailleurs n'aura pas
lieu
qui n'aura pas lieu puisque la justice a
considéré qu' il fallait l'écarter d'un
revers de main il ya aussi d'autres
affaires qui ont été révélées je pense à
ce que nous savons désormais sur le pnf
d'actes parfois de prénationale
financier qualifié de debré a three
judiciaire de sorte d' enquêtes de
contrebande à la limite
à la limite ce que la justice se doit
pouvoir faire avec des avocats qui ont
été géolocalisé qui en sauf que quand
vous dites à bruno terios et on se
demande quand on vous dit ça qui a
demandé à ce qu'il y ait ces écoutes
en tout cas ces pressions et au bénéfice
de qui c'est la question qui se pose
c'est mais cette question je ne veux pas
y répondre
parce que quoi parce que ça voudrait
trop loin parce qu'il ya deux hypothèses
parce que soit il ya une hypothèse
politique soit il ya une autre hypothèse
c'est que il ya une partie et je ne veux
pas généraliser de la magistrature qui
se considèrent investi d'une mission et
qu'il devrait peut-être un ressentiment
vis-à-vis du pouvoir politique
moi je ne sais pas mais en tout cas il
ya une forme de politisation qui est
inquiétante et il ya un doute qui est
désormais jetés sur la justice se doute
il est d'autant plus grave j'essaie de
peser mes mots mais je sais que ils sont
lourds de signification
on voit bien que la participation d'hier
a été extrêmement faible on voit le
climat de défiance
je pense que quand une grande
institution justement sont précisément
interrogé en matière de comment
dirais-je da partialité
il ya un vrai problème il ya un vrai
souci kate mais si on revenir affronter
leurs pratiques pour revenir à françois
fillon il est sous le coup de cette
décision de justice maintenant
ses avocats ont fait appel on peut
imaginer que françois fillon ayant
prison non mais d'abord la première
instance c'est souvent une instance de
l'émotion je pense que l'instance de
l'appel c'est souvent l'instance du
droit donc ce jugement n'est pas un
jugement définitif
les juges la justice peut se tromper
c'est d'ailleurs pour cela que les
droits de tout justiciable c'est de
faire à douelle fois heureusement il ya
des procédures d'un état d'une dernière
chose simplement simplement ce que je
considère c'est que depuis plusieurs
jours on a vu que la justice avait été
accélérés dans un certain nombre de cas
elle s'était même acharné pour essayer
de prouver par exemple que l'ancien
président de république était forcément
coupable que un ancien premier ministre
qui se présentait à une élection
présidentielle
il a fallu là aussi accélérer les
poursuites pour ses dix qualifiés sa
candidature la démocratie a été faussée
il y a des doutes sur l'impartialité des
juges alors eric ciotti député et l'ère
des alpes-maritimes demande la
suppression du parquet national
financier va faire une proposition de
loi dans ce sens est ce que vous allez
dans ce sens vous moi je pense qu'il ya
une vraie interrogation faut le
supprimer ou para pense que eric ciotti
a raison de poser le problème
simplement je pense que cela ne suffit
pas
je pense qu'il faut le supprimer vous
n'avez pas répondu - oui je pense que il
est mal née je pense que françois
hollande s'était tiré d'affaires cahuzac
a avec une proposition qui avait
l'apparence en réalité delà de la bonne
réponse de la juste réponse mais que en
réalité et c'était assez machiavélique
il s'agissait simplement d'avoir une
sorte de machine de guerre aussi avec
des gens nommés dont on sait que ils
vous sont proches politiquement et qui
ont la haute main en quoi mais quand
vous concentrer les affaires dans un
seul lieu c'est beaucoup plus facile
évidemment de surveillance se supprimer
simplement simple mais pour ce que je
veux dire non je ne conclut pas parce
que la question n'est pas l'indépendance
la question c'est de l'impartialité et
je pense que elle concerne bien sûr le
recrutement je pense qu'il faut
diversifier diversifier le recrutement
des magistrats
je pense qu'il ya indications de
déroulement de carrière entre le siège
de parquets entre ses allées et venues
entre les cabinets ministériels etc je
pense par ailleurs qu'il ya une question
de responsabilité
est ce que les juges peuvent être la
seule catégorie de français qui soit
responsable devant rien le président de
république a saisi le conseil national
supérieur de la magistrature
entre 2015 et 2018 il y à 1048 saisine
du csm
deux seulement saisines ont été jugés
recevables
savez vous combien ils font de sanctions
00 vous souvenez du juge burgaud
avec le scandale de trop il a été nommé
il ya deux ou trois ans je crois avocat
général référendaire à la cour de
cassation il a poursuivi son ascension
si j'ose dire
donc c'est tout le fonctionnement de la
justice dont poser la question aussi des
responsabilités
faisons attention parce que là encore
c'est une question de la confiance dans
nos institutions
donc je crois que ne disons pas que tout
la justice a un problème de partialité
mais essayons néanmoins de traiter des
problèmes on ne peut pas en tout cas
fermez les yeux lorsque il y à des
dysfonctionnements graves et qui sont
désormais claires à v ray voilà pour
cette réélection sans que vous étiez
truche et puis c'est évidemment
l'actualité chaude de cette journée on
va cueillir maintenant brigitte boucher
de lcp soir gîte ransart francis bonsoir
bruno retailleau bonsoir à vous même
l'une ici pas là et un taux d'abstention
record hier pour ce second tour 58,4
pour cent est ce que vous y voyez un
rejet du monde politique dans son
ensemble
en tout cas je vois un malaise même une
impasse démocratique c'est un pas
démocratique du reste gelé déclarait il
ya quelques heures on voit bien qu'en
france il ya deux perdants il ya un
désastre pour en marche il est très très
clair mais aussi une autre défaite pour
le rassemblement national qui perd à peu
près la moitié de ses élus municipaux
or c'est précisément cette affiche là ce
duel qu'on nous dit indépassable qu'on
voudrait nous imposer pour les
présidentielles de 2022 il ya quelque
chose qui ne va pas moi je pense que ce
malaise démocratique cette crise cette
fatigue démocratique elle vient de loin
je ne dis pas que mène macron en est
l'unique responsable je dis simplement
qu'il a accéléré quand on voit la
gestion par exemple de la crise
sanitaire mais parce qu'il ya une
impuissance de l'état quand on voit que
l'état n'a pas été capable par exemple
de mettre à disposition de nous
soignants en temps voulu des masques ou
pour le dépistage des tests c'est
interroge quand on voit qu'il sait que
l'amateurisme l'inexpérience sont la
matrice il l'a revendiqué c'est pas moi
qui vous utilisent ce terme ce terme là
souvenez-vous lorsqu'il a reçu les
députés file des amas soyez fiers d et
des amateurs
évidemment on le croit on le croit donc
l'amateurisme sa cause des dégâts
simplement il ya aussi le désordre que
tous les français peuvent voir le
désordre dans la rue regardez dijon la
sphère de dijon a été traitée cette
risque entre des bandes rivales des
communautés rivales sap a été traitée à
la préfecture au commissariat ça a été
traitée finalement à la mosquée ça doit
interroger des français le désordre
il est aussi dans les esprits avec une
inversion des valeurs
alors qu'on dit que notre police de
gendarmerie et coupable alors qu'eux ils
sont souvent les premières classées pour
le constat c'est pour le compte a alors
brisé les boulons et statues volume nous
dit emile 2 0
il ya la république en marche et il ya
le rassemblement national les
républicains ont perdu dans les grandes
villes
je pense à bordeaux possiblement à
marseille vous est injuste est-ce que
vous avez un problème de cette indéfini
est-ce que vous avez un problème avec le
vote urbain à tanger par la grande bleue
vous vous dites mais vous pas sur nice
nous l'avons gagnée toulouse nous
l'avons gagné et on a gagné bientôt
exposée aux kurdes à 60% des villes de
plus de 30 mille habitants alors moi je
dis attention on peut pas fanfaronner
pourquoi parce que ceux qui ont gagné ce
sont nous mère et ceux qui transpose ce
succès local et qui voudraient en faire
une grande victoire nationale jardy
attention et on a effectivement un souci
c'est que il faut qu'on trouve les mots
pour pouvoir convaincre notamment
l'électorat urbain et l'élection de
dimanche à dessiner
finalement plusieurs france il faudrait
d'ailleurs réassocier le premier tour en
réalité on a eu deux élections
un second tour à trois mois du premier
tour c'est une nouvelle excuse mais on
voit bien
2 comment dirais-je 2 france on a une
france qui est préoccupé par la fin du
monde
les urbains et qui ont un souci
écologique très prenant et vous ne savez
pas leur parler c'est ce que rien et qui
n'ont pas de problèmes de fin de mois
mais vous n'allez pas leur part aux
autres france n'avait pas de réponse je
penserai à ses lecteurs ici mais ce que
ce que je veux vous dire c'est qu'on a
d'énormes primes je pense qu'on doit
pouvoir trouver des réponses d'écologie
de droite parce que dans nos mandats
locaux dans la note et beaucoup de mer
il ya bien longtemps que île déserte par
exemple sans avoir dé désherbants keith
wade sait quoi l'écologie de droite ou
chimique
aujourd'hui c'est quoi et bien justement
leur profession est bien l'écologie de
droite c'est d'abord une écologie qui ne
soit pas une nouvelle religion ça n'est
pas une idéologie on doit sortir
l'écologie justement du gauchisme et
conclat concrètement c'est faire
confiance à la science
concrètement c'est de faire en sorte que
par exemple si on se donne comme
objectif la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique
on se donne comme objectif d'avoir un
mix d'abord décarbonée donc on n'est pas
dans l'anti nucléaire puisque l'énergie
nucléaire c'est pas bruno retailleau qui
le dit c'est le giec
tous les scenarii sont trop du giec
reconnaissent qu' on a besoin d'une
énergie nucléaire alors on va fermer
fait ce justement on a fait
et on nous n'avons pas nous n'avons pas
justement d'énergie qui sera qui
pourront monter en puissance dans les
tons de la fermeture donc on va importer
une énergie d'y voir dit il aurait fallu
laisser ouvert fessenheim ça va pas dans
le sens de l'histoire il faut pas aller
vers plus de renouvelable c'est pas ça
que vous défoncer au jour dans ce non je
pense qu'il faut un socle qui se voit un
socle d'énergie nucléaire avec un socle
d'énergies renouvelables vous savez
c'est très très difficile
les urbains pour ça il faut ce sont des
urbains par exemple en matière
d'éoliennes se sont pas les urbains qui
voit les éoliennes poussé en ville ce
sont bien souvent les habitants de la
ruralité ou des petites villes donc
c'est vrai je joue on verra des
éoliennes sur les immeubles ont écouté
la vue de ce j'étais un de ceux qui a
promu une plateforme aux flottes de
d'ailleurs dans vendait des pays de la
loire mais on pas on parle d'écologie le
premier ministère de l'environnement
c'était vous c'était la droite là le
grenelle de l'environnement la charte de
l'environnement le président président
hissène alors justement nous casser les
villages écologiques de la droite il est
le mien eh bien je vais vous le dire je
pense que nos mères depuis longtemps se
sont saisis du problème dans leurs
cantines et circuits courts notamment en
matière de tri etc
je pourrais vous en parler longtemps on
entendait aussi rimer le préjudice
écologique ne vous crédite pas
d'écologie le préjudice écologique qui
l'a fait passer dans le code civil c'est
votre serviteur c'est pas un élu
justement écologique tôt on a notre
actif un certain nombre de bilans
le problème c'est que souvent c'est un
bilan local c'est un deal en queue on a
fait moi j'avais suivi pour le préjudice
écologique
la catastrophe avec le conseil
départemental de la vendée la case of de
la marée noire de l'erika rue et on n'a
pas su traduire on n'a pas su
conceptualité au niveau national notre
expérience au niveau local eh bien on va
le faire et l'écologique nous voulons
c'est une écologie de bon sens et ne
soit pas idéologique qui fasse confiance
à l'innovation à la science une question
de brigitte alors allez-y alors ce matin
emmanuel macron a annoncé d'autres
convention citoyenne pour le climat vous
savez qu'il a reçues les 150 membres de
la convention qui l'avait installé il a
également annoncé deux référendum
est ce que pour vous on parlait tout à
l'heure de la crise démocratique est ce
que c'est une bonne réponse à cette
crise justement assez l'inversé celle
inverse c'est précisément l'inversé
c'est avec ce genre de gadget
que on va dire le référendum vous êtes
gaulliste un gadget je parle de la
convention citoyenne je parle de 150
personnes qui sont tirés au sort et dont
on pourrait penser qu'elles vont
représenter 60 millions 60,6 millions
même de français je pense que 1 le
tirage au sort c'est une régression
démocratie c'est la démocratie du hasard
la démocratie de la roulette russe
c'est ensuite une démocratie qui est
manipulé puisque ces gens là sont pris
en compte en charge par un certain
nombre de gens qui les ont craint ces
propositions il n'y a aucune légitimité
à cette connaître quand je lis par
exemple monsieur cyril dion ils se
cachent pas ils avaient dit coûté la
démocratie représentative et n'est pas
capable de prendre des mesures
suffisamment radical justement pour
faire face au changement climatique avec
des mesures qui doivent être de l'ordre
de la décroissance donc il ne se cache
pas c'est cette fausse démocratie est en
réalité un modèle conçu une date comme
un contre modèle de la démocratie
représentative donc mme dhalla qui
minent la confiance dans la démocratie
représentative et c'est ce qu'a fait
même mâcon depuis le départ alors en
essayant de justifier au parlement et
les élus sauf que justement emmanuel
macron a dit que tout allait passer
quand même devant le parlement
il y aura des votes dans chaque chambre
et notamment pour la révision de la
constitution sur l'article 20 par
exemple le référendum vous êtes d'accord
au prix attendez vous avez compris
quelque chose sur les référendums
ça va être en 2021 c'est ça ce qui va le
faire vraiment elle dénoncé non mais
avec mm macro
c'est ça qui était je pense qu'il
portera l'histoire le dira une très
lourde responsabilité vis-à-vis de cette
crise démocratique
la devise c'est eux semblent faire et
faire semblant
à chaque fois regarder pour le ceta en
matière écologique nous au sénat nous
nous y opposons donc d'accord lundi
devant l'assemblée de la beauté en
marche la voter mais on ne nous traduit
pas on le sait ça ne vient pas au sénat
parce que c'est qu'au sénat nous allons
nous y opposer et si la révision de la
constitution est ce que vous voterez
l'article 1 pour réviser la constitution
et ya intégré le réchauffement
climatique vers à écouter on verra mais
on est l'opposé à ça vous n'êtes a fait
la bringue simplement j'attends de voir
parce que avec les mêmes acron j'ai
appris à distinguer ce qui tier 2 lors
de la parole du disque où a priori vous
n'êtes pas posez vous avez dit je verrai
en fonction de la rédaction qu'on nous
donnera mais encore une fois je crains
que ce soit plus
en cosmétique que vous criez pas au
tripatouillage de la constitution dans
ce cas là je n'en j'attends de voir
exactement ce qu'est le bon voilà
heureusement cette idée de placer tout
en haut de la norme les droits de la
nature au dessus des droits humains
c'était prendre position non merci
brigitte ça très vite le temps avant
d'accueillir thème traduit tout à
l'heure une petite question revient sur
les mythes sade marseille vous avez vu
michel rubio là le printemps marseille
est arrivée dix points devant les listes
de martine vassal qui elle-même et l'air
à l'est républicain qui elle même a été
battu dans son secteur
martine vassal dit qu'elle revendique
quand même la mairie de marseille
puisque ça va jouer au troisième tour si
vous voulez qui va élire le maire est ce
que ce serait moralement tôt nabeul que
martine vassal devienne maire de
marseille
mais ce qui est moral en démocratie
c'est les règles de la démocratie
grecque du premier tour et du deuxième
tour est réglée du troisième tour
voilà donc où puisque c'est une question
de secteur oui à paris ça n'a pas été le
cas cergy juste moralement seulement
moralement ça n'est pas la question
la question de la mort pas de morale et
technique si c'est la question de la
démocratie si c'est conforme si le
troisième tour est conforme aux règles
et que ces règles ne sont pas faussés
alors c'est démocratique et c'est donc
démocratiquement moral est donc martine
vassal v il faut trouver une coalition
ou bien martine vassal trouve une
coalition ou bien elle ne la trouve pas
ces mêmes rumeurs là qu'est la troupe
elle est élue et si martine vassal avait
le renfort des voies du rassemblement
national vous diriez que ce serait bien
non d'ailleurs monsieur ravier vous
savez ne sera plus maire de ses jambes
il y aura des airs elle ramènera des
raids
donc est ce que est ce que s'il y avait
le rn qui venaient en sueur de martine
vassal ce sera une jeune fille au
téléphone et croyez moi c'est parce
qu'elle m'a dit souhaiter très bien on
va accueillir maintenant thème traduit
de public sénat
sur table bonsoir francis bonsoir bruno
retailleau
bonsoir on va parler des sénatoriales
alain vous êtes président du groupe
majoritaire au sénat le groupe lrs
qu'après cette municipale vous êtes
assurés pour vous de garder la majorité
au sénat
non mais c'est municipal lacets
municipal là ne bouleverse pas vous
l'avez compris en tout cas la situation
de la majorité sénatoriale la droite est
et le centre puisque donc ça va rester
et l'air et éventuellement avec ce
centre je pense même que la majorité
pourrait être confortée en tout cas elle
sera consolidée
je crois que c'est plutôt le groupe en
marche qui va être prise en difficulté
et dans ce cas donc si et bien c'est
bien la droite qui est majoritaire est
ce que vous souhaitez que gérard larcher
soit candidat à sa succession sera je le
souhaite je pense que gérard larcher
je le connais intimement je ne connais
pas de politique ou de femmes politiques
qui connaissent aussi profondément et et
charnellement la france dans sa
profondeur
il a une connaissance exceptionnelle
aussi mais c'est pas une connaissance
intellectuelle ou livresque c'est une
connaissance encore une fois j'ai
utilisé le mot charnelle tout à l'heure
parce que c'est de cet ordre là
et malheureusement il ya de moins en
moins d'hommes politiques qui
connaissent la france dans ces paysages
dans ces visages à la fois dans ses
traditions mais d'être dans ses talents
dans ces énergies et je crois que la
france c'est une population de ce sont
des territoires déjà à l'archet en tout
cas non je crois que c'est la réalité
est attendu c'est avec lui je pense que
le sénat a à retrouver une place au
coeur du débat public pourquoi parce que
le sénat sans doute parce que la
majorité à l'assemblée nationale et et
troupe vie c'est à l'exécutif est bien
la séparation des pouvoirs entre
l'exécutif et le législatif
c'est le rôle du sénat et je pense
qu'une démocratie c'est pas seulement
suffrage universel c'est aussi la
séparation des pouvoirs
si ça n'était que le suffrage universel
la démocratie monsieur poutine
moussières de gan seraient de grands
démocrates vous avez parlé des
difficultés de la république en marche
sébastien lecornu
le ministre chargé des collectivités
tente de débaucher par et il est bien
dans les groupes au sénat pour pouvoir
rallier les maquereaux compet
et lorsque vous êtes sur vous de tous
les membres de votre groupe courage
d'ailleurs d'ailleurs c'est non mais
votre question est un neveu puisque
plutôt que de gagner dans l'urne
en réalité des élus des sénateurs des
sénatrices pour composer un groupe
solide
ils se disent on va essayer de faire du
débauchage pas ça peut marcher
est ce que ça peut marcher dans ses pas
toujours marcher parce que vous avez
toujours des hommes et des femmes qui
peuvent être impressionné par le pouvoir
mais le débauchage ces quelques unités
et vous fera les comptes
on fera les comptes lesparre en
septembre c'est assez vite laissant
septembre et je lui souhaite beaucoup de
courage
c'est beaucoup de courage le débauchage
ça existe quand même chez les verts on
parle de guillaume larrivé de geoffroy
didier et même votre homologue à
l'assemblée nationale damien abad us en
citer parmi ceux qui seraient tentés de
rentrer au gouvernement qu est ce que
vous leur dites moi ce que je vous dis
c'est que vous lisez trop la pression je
peux vous dire que je ne vois pas du
tout par exemple ce n'est pas un bad
rentrer dans ce gouvernement non puis
j'ai vu de tout ça c'est une affaire de
casting qui sera le patron c'est
emmanuel macron et il fera sa propre
politique
je les ai vus puisqu'on a déjeuné avec
lui avec les présidents de groupe la
semaine dernière j'ai vu quelqu'un qui
était qui ne changeait pas immuable sûr
de lui fier de lui s'étonnant à chaque
instant de sa propre intelligence et
ceux qui pensent à une réinvention
ça c'est des histoires pour les
midinettes salalah la réinvention est
une invention des mails macron on va
continuer à parler élections mais d'un
autre scrutin puisque on va parler et
bien du possible report qui est
envisagée par emmanuel macron report des
élections départementales régionales
prévues en mars 2021 pour lui il dit en
tout cas la priorité c'est la relance
est-ce que ça s'entend parce que vous
êtes d'accord avec cet argument non la
priorité c'est sa propre élection est
pour m justement en difficulté un
certain nombre de présidents de région
qui pourraient lesquels un concurrent
comme valérie pécresse comme xavier
bertrand mais il y aura pas que je vous
rassure il se dit bah voilà nous en
donnera de l'argent aux départements et
régions qu'à la condition que
ils nous aident à repousser pratiquement
de 18 mois vous vous rendez compte
le calendrier électoral je veux dire ce
que je veux dire c'est que ce soit de ce
genre de magouille
ça y est maintenant le sait on connaît
et on ne connaît les raisons comment
comment un chef d'état j'espère qu'il
est aussi un homme d'état petit proposer
ce genre de solution qui consiste à
abîmer la démocratie la démocratie c'est
le respect des règles le respect des
règles on en parlait il ya quelques
instants
c'est aussi le respect d'un calendrier
électoral onpe pas bidouiller un
calendrier électoral en fonction de ses
intérêts personnels
c'est d'ailleurs je dis là c'est quand
même bizarre au moment des municipales
il fallait aller vite pour installer les
maires le plus vite possible pour
répondre à la crise est là il faudrait
retarder l'élection des présidents de
départements des présidents de région
parce que ce serait nuisible à une
reprise à une relance une vache y
retrouve pas ses veaux comme on dit chez
moi vendu vous seriez rosselet à
l'instant de xavier bertrand de valérie
pécresse qui sont qui pourraient être
des adversaires emmanuel macron en 2022
à la présidentielle ils ont claqué la
porte de l air il pourrait néanmoins
être pour vous un candidat soutenu par l
air en 2022
vous pourriez soutenir l'un ou l'autre
non mais la question des présidentielles
tant d on a eu hier c'était les
municipales demain les seniors c'est
maintenant on est tout de suite aux
présidentielles ce que je dis moi depuis
le début c'est que il faut éviter le
pire
c'est quoi le pire pour nous c'est à
dire l air mais aussi des gens qui
étaient dans notre famille et qui sont
partis comme valérie pécresse comme
xavier bertrand qui sont de personnes de
qualité bien le pire c'est que l'on
fasse du premier tour des
présidentielles la primaire parce que si
on a deux ou trois candidats issus de la
droite et du centre au premier au
premier tour des présidentielles on sera
automatiquement dégagé c'est une équipe
organiser une primaire pour au moins
pour moi je pense que la primaire est
peut-être le plus mauvais des systèmes
mais à l'exception tous les autres je ne
vois pas quelle autre système peut
déposer des primaires des candidats de
l'intérieur ait l'air et des candidats
de l'extérieur voilà pris l'extérieur
vous conter et xavier bertrand avait
répété à l'excès
l extérieur de l air est interdit pour
unis pour vous oui il peut y avoir
différents points soulevés par exemple y
avoir moi il peut peut-être avoir
d'autres peut-être c'est pas sûr encore
au vous y serez non mais attendez je
n'ai le 29 journée le 29 juin et vous me
parlez d'une élection présidentielle il
se passera beaucoup de choses
moi ce que j'aimerais en tout cas c'est
que on puisse proposer aux français
autre chose d'ailleurs que le fameux la
fameuse les deux têtes d'affiché mêmes
macro et marine le pen par son
destinataire des sondages pour l'instant
offre exactement et encore après dans
les sondages 75% des français n'en
veulent pas tuer la raison pour laquelle
je vous dis ça exactement dont la
licence on est d'accord alors une
dernière question gérard larcher doit
présenter jeudi ses 50 propositions en
matière de décentralisation
quelle sera sa mesure phare et c'est pas
une mesure phare c'est la mesure phare
c'est de se dire que notre démocratie
elle est abîmée que la confiance elle
aussi elle est accordée de façon très
restrictive par nos compatriotes et la
démocratie on doit la reconstruire par
le haut et par le bas
le bas c'est parce que la notion de
proximité
je dis souvent le lieu c'est le lien
c'est parce que c'est dans la proximité
qu'on tisse des liens les uns avec les
autres parce qu'on se connaît si j'ose
dire le visage à visage de regard hagard
donc il ya cette question de la
démocratie c'est aussi dans la proximité
qu'on établit +22 d'efficacité et on l'a
vu on a un état bureaucratique qui a
montré ses insuffisances
au moment de la gestion de la crise
sanitaire donc je crois que on doit
ouvrir si j'ose dire les choses les
perspectives pour les collectivités
donner plus de liberté ne pas avoir peur
des expérimentations de la
différenciation déconcentré l'état au
niveau départemental il va falloir
engager une vraie étape de la
décentralisation
mais vous savez ça n'est pas que des
lois c'est une pratique parce que toute
l'histoire de la décentralisation en
france c'est une histoire où l'état
d'abord à cordes d'une main et puis il
reprend de l'autre main donc il faudra
qu'on trouve des clics et pour faire en
sorte que on arrive y compris dans la
constitution à avoir oui absolument
laquelle par exemple sur le principe qui
décident paye quand on nous a imposé des
rythmes scolaires paris décide et la
province et à
les villes devait s'exécuter et payer
non non le principe de responsabilité je
pense qu'il faut une décentralisation
qui soit responsable prison république
je n'ai entendu le souhaitent et bien je
pense que la responsabilité c'est aussi
la décision c'est aussi celui qui paye à
merci
tam herti en attendant il ya emmanuel
macron aujourd'hui qui en recevant les
citoyens de la convention pour le climat
a proposé de débloquer 15 milliards
d'euros pour la conversion écologique et
il dit lui ça servira le plan de relance
économique on va l'entendre prendra
toute sa part c'est pourquoi dès le plan
de relance que nous sommes en train de
préparer 15 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires sur deux ans seront
injectés dans la conversion écologique
de notre économie pour une autre
retailleau c'est bien ça pour relancer
l'économie ce une bonne idée
j'attends de voir qui était j'attends de
voir ce serait quoi la bonne idée pour
vous par exemple dans ces 15 milliards
pour la transition écologique vous vous
verriez ça dans investi dans quoi
d'abord les trop jeunes moi je crois
beaucoup beaucoup à hydrogène je pense
malheureusement que les chinois on nous
ont passé par dessus la tête notamment
en matière d'électricité surtout de
batterie on a beaucoup de mal à les
supplanter je pense que il faut voir le
coup d'après le long terme c'est
l'hydrogène
pour vous donner un exemple nous on a un
petit plan de 100 millions d'euros pour
l'hydrogène
les allemands c'est une centaine de
l'hydrogène pour la voiture voulait dire
je pense que d'abord l'hydrogène c'est
pour les gros véhicules ça peut être
pour les bateaux notamment pour les
camions que c'était et c'est quelque
chose d'extrêmement vertueux on augmente
d'ailleurs l'autonomie voilà ensuite
évidemment jeu pour les mobilités et
aussi pour le logement
je suis puisque ce sont ces deux grands
secteurs qui favorise notamment les gaz
à effet de serre donc il faut absolument
magie un paquet sur ces deux points mais
ce que j'observe c'est que dans la loi
de finances notamment et en 2019 en
marche avait détricoter la prime à la
reconversion
mais aussi la le crédit d'impôt sur la
transition énergétique donc on nous
retire le corps y est c'est toujours le
en même temps on détricote un jour et
qu'on essaie de refaire le lendemain
donc sa note de yoni à beaucoup de
français c'est que pendant que vous
répondiez à cette question vous avez vu
il ya deux parlementaires qu'ils sont
sont installés bonsoir on va les
accueillir deux parlementaires c'est
c'est la formule d'auditions publiques
verville bonsoir merci d'un but d'être
le porte parole des députés la
république en marge député des côtes
d'armor et bonsoir david assouline vous
connaissez mieux j'imagine puisque david
assouline sénateur ps de paris donc
sénateurs c'est plus facile que de
connaître peut-être les députés voilà en
tout cas vous faites vous fait que les
sens on va commencer par david assouline
parce que vous êtes un proche vous
voulez revenir david assouline sur les
municipales et les stratégies d'alliance
la république en marche et dlr oui
d'abord parce que c'est ce serait
incongru d'avoir un débat là le
lendemain des municipales sans l'évoquer
et j'ai remarqué s'était pas joué mais
en tous les cas la sanction n' est qu'
il y a eu un espèce de front dans un
certain nombre de grandes villes la
république en marche et les républicains
que vous représentez pour absolument
empêcher que les écologistes ou les
socialistes en tous les cas cette
alliance paul que nous avons créé puisse
gagner un certain nombre de villes et
partout c'est l'échec
on va voir marseille si ya pas trop de
magouilles derrière mais il ya dix
points d'avance bon mais alors votre
question il ya bordeaux diviser c'est
l'échec assuré
cette question c'est clairement par
exemple est bon voilà donc strasbourg
biens dont je vous laisse vous êtes
interpellé
qu'est ce que voulait demander à bruno
retailleau du coup donc je comprends pas
parce qu'on y lit à il y à une critique
sans arrêt relativement radical de la
politique du gouvernement ou pourra
revenir sur le fond d'ailleurs mais en
réalité quand il ya ce danger de la
gauche
vous avez testé en tous les cas ce front
possi alors pour vous il n'ya pas pire
on aurait relativise d'ailleurs les
différences fondamentales autre que de
postes et de pouvoir
que vous avez avec la politique de
droite bruno retailleau vous répond je
pense moins que cette confusion était
sans doute une erreur et que dès lors
qu'on brouille les convictions notre
électorat ne s'y retrouvent plus et ne
s'est pas mobilisée évidemment alors
c'est clair
vous avez vu enfin c'est clair alors
c'est carré en même temps je me permets
de rajouter
donc quand laurent wauquiez venez venez
c'est venez à je veux des outils comme
laurent wauquiez décide de soutenir
gérard collomb et la république en
marche à lyon il a tort donc
ah non mais je moi je pense très fort
donc je pense très franchement que 1
ça n'était en aucun cas d accord qui
avait été décidée au niveau de notre
parti politique beaucoup que ça n'engage
que laurent wauquiez eu le crâne au
gange que christian jacob qui est député
au sic et président de l air a bien
indiqué qu'il s'agissait d' accords
locaux mais je pense qu'on voit bien que
ces accords sont pour l'avenir une
erreur parce que ça désappointé les
membres de votre parti donc vous lui
dites vous a fait une erreur laurent
wauquiez vous essayez de nous vous avez
très bien compris mais ce que je vous
dis c'est que dans la politique c'est la
clarté des convictions et et quand on
n'a pas assez de cartes et des
convictions en réalité ce qui s'est
passé c'est que l'alliance que nous
avons noué sur quelques points
particuliers vous savez il ya trente
cinq mille communes à cela concerne
quelques comme une lampe à lyon c'est
pas n'importe quoi oui non bien sûr bien
sûr c'est les communes symbolique
c'était de la métropole et puis et puis
la ville mais on voit bien qu'on perd en
marge nous a tirés vers le bas mot après
ça je sais pas si c'est un mot mais je
suis pas venu faire le journaliste et
poser des questions là mais il y avait
barré qui veut oui mais vous m'avez
demandé de poser une question et
derrière il va du nom il m'a répondu
mais j'ai à lui répondre à ça la vidéo
s'il vous plaît bon alors répondu que
non mais nous parce que c'est si c'est
facile qu'après coup vous disiez c'est
une erreur mais avant vous a pas entendu
dire un bon donc globalement ce que je
veux dire c'est que sur le fond vous
défendez
la même politique économique et sociale
mais vous voulez pire que ce café macro
et ce qui est désavoué du président de
la république et de leur politique
par exemple vous vouliez 500 mille
fonctionnaires de moins qu'avec la
crésus qu'ovide jeu c'était la
présidence des jeunes 17
vous pensez que c'est une erreur et oui
alors c'était une erreur de jeunesse
cause dans la crise une bobine je crois
pas que ce que les français ont aperçu
c'était qu'il y avait trop de
fonctionnaires et de gens pour des
finances et auteuil a laissé une ville
semailles vous êtes d'accord avec lui de
ne pas venir travailler encore avec lui
le temps de travail martin hirsch qui
est un homme de droite
c'est le patron d'ap et hp le poteau de
paille disait il ya quelques semaines
que c'était clair les 35 heures avaient
abouti à croire à martin hirsch étaient
calmes et faiblesses de la région
soutenant les 15 dernières années est
bien des personnels soignants les 35
heures on appauvrit les français et 35
heures ont mis à mal
l'hôpital public voilà parce qu'il
aurait fallu parce qu'il aurait fallu en
même temps de faire les 35 heures et sur
l'hôpital public embaucher des dizaines
des dizaines et des dizaines de milliers
n'avait pas les moyens mais vous vous
êtes pas battus pour embaucher à
l'époque justement encore plus débauché
à ce propos hervé berville voulez parlez
vous du ségur de la santé parce que
c'est elle est en débat en ce moment
enfin en discussion et vous les
interrogez justement non merci d'abord
de l'invitation c'était bien évidemment
on voit bien que la crise a montré qu'il
fallait réinvestir dans la santé dans la
proximité aussi dans les services
sanitaires de proximité et aux faux
qu'il fallait à la fois mieux rémunérer
nos soignants ce qui n'a pas été fait
quand vous étiez au pouvoir ce qui n'a
pas été fait quand vous étiez au pouvoir
puisque l'argent qui était investi dans
l'hôpital a fortement réduit et ce à
tout le monde tous les spectateurs
pourront regarder dans les différents
budgets et puis il ya aussi une
responsabilité vous avez quand vous avez
été au gouvernement c'est que vous savez
moi j'ai jamais te convient à partir
était au gouvernement
gouvernement et quand votre premier à
vous soutenir françois fillon était 1er
mai avait raison en des 35 heures ont
largement déstabiliser le système de
santé il ya deux autres choses qui ont
déstabilisé système de santé
la première c'est la tarification à
l'acte qui a fait qu'on est rentrés dans
la question d'hôpital dans une logique
financière une logique budgétaire qui a
détruit la capacité de nos soignants à
mettre l'humain au coeur et roselyne
bachelot oui mais cette confiance
et puis le deuxième élément qui a été là
aussi dramatique c'était cette loi qui
visait au fond à enlever du pouvoir de
décision médecin pour le donner à des
directeurs d'hôpitaux qui étaient plutôt
des gestionnaires dont alors maintenant
qu'on a une crise qui est derrière nous
on l'espère sur la question sédentaires
et que nous mêmes dans cette majorité on
doit mettre encore plus d'argent sur la
question de la santé quel est le plan
des républicains sur ce sujet crucial
important des républicains sachant que
vous avez participé fortement à le
casser le plan des républicains ça n'est
pas de faire une succession de plans
comme vous avez fait on est déjà on va
être au quatrième plan mais vous avez eu
le temps de faire plein de plans entre
autres non mais vous vous avez
additionner des plans en 18 mois ça veut
bien dire qu'aucun plan n'était efficace
et on a une gestion de la crise
sanitaire qui a été calamiteuse c'est
clair et net on a malheureusement la
france va avoir un soignant et deux
millions d'habitants
extrait la maison important je crois
pour vous répondre que si nous voulons
redresser l'hôpital il ya sans doute une
question de moyens et au sénat au plfss
nous avons été et nous avons créé
d'ailleurs un certain nombre d'incidents
séance pour dire que l'ondam
c'est-à-dire l'objectif comptable
n'était pas suffisant pour l'hôpital et
nous avons justement pu redresser un
sérum de choses et d'ailleurs nièce
musin à l'époque nous en avait remercié
première chose dont nous n'ignorons pas
qu'il faille investir dans la santé vous
reconnaissez le jour vous avez fait à
casser l'hôpital chauveau le
reconnaissait sans - non mais attendez
laissez moi parler on va les séries
rangs de la droite a jamais fait
d'erreur
évidemment je vous dire j'aime ça jamais
je vous dirai ça évidemment bon et moi
j'ai pété au gouvernement je me sens pas
lié du tout de cette façon là avec une
solidarité avec ceux qui nous ont
précédés maintenant si on veut vous
venez la lettre si on veut absolument si
vous voulez relever le l'hôpital 1
vous ne pouvez pas seulement réattribuer
toujours plus de moyens parce que nous
avons déjà en europe dans l' ocde
nous sommes le pays qui dépense le plus
pour sa santé ça veut dire que il faut
bien sûr accompagné au niveau budgétaire
mais il faut donner plus de pouvoir aux
médecins il faut sans doute régionaliser
un certain nombre de choses moi je suis
pour la régionalisation drs voilà avec
un objectif alors régionales on sent
s'est déconcentré s'est déconcentré
c'est pas du tout c'est pas nous c'est
de boire aux régions là je pense que les
par exemple les régions pourraient
financer tout ce qui est de l'ordre de
l'immobilier ça n'est pas la sécurité
sociale de le faire c'est à dire pour
acheter les hôpitaux en tout cas ce que
je dis c'est que on n'améliorera pas la
l'hôpital la situation de l'hôpital
uniquement avec toujours plus d'argent
public
on revoit la gouvernance on régionalise
beaucoup plus on donne plus de fonds
ayant d'ailleurs aux médecins plutôt que
administratif et pour terminer on à la
différence une différence énorme 34 % de
personnels administratifs dans l'hôpital
français au danemark 20 % en allemagne
24 % la différence entre l'allemagne et
nous c'est plus de cent mille postes
cent mille postes administratifs et bien
il ya une partie de ces postes
administratifs qu'on ferait mieux bien
un de reverser en personnel soignant on
aurait toujours rêver quelques
l'administration mais c'est un mot amour
puis davidas au lycée cette
dramatisation qui convoitent les balles
avec les 35000 que vous m participe à
faire la bureaucratisation c'est vous
qui avez créé les arias
david assouline vous disiez aussi que
vous vouliez parler à bruno retailleau
de son rôle au sénat de son rôle au
sénat pampa en général nos noms de des
différences qu'il y a de fonds entre
nous bosco sénat il ya pas mal de sujets
notamment puisqu'ils sont dans
l'opposition et
il découvre qu'il faut vraiment défendre
les droits du parlement et c'est assez
sincère et on mène beaucoup de combat
ensemble pour que le parlement soit
respectée parce que c'est le jeune ans
assis et je pense que ça fait que
l'actuel pouvoir a été loin dans cette
remise en cause du travail parlementaire
pour moi qui suis parlementaire
maintenant depuis un certain temps je le
constate tous les jours mais je constate
que ces derniers mois bruno retailleau
comme chef de parti la personne même de
groupe
lapsus très fin d'année oui non mais ce
que je veux dire c'est c'est dans son
rôle de représentant des républicains
par des ppl par des combats acharnés
qu'ils mènent parfois personnellement
dans l'hémicycle met en avant tout ce
qu'il ya de plus réactionnaires dans ce
que la droite a pu défendre dans notre
pays on le voit monter au créneau quand
c'était la loi bioéthique pour remettre
en cause la pma on le voit faire une loi
dite anti casseurs qui instruit le droit
de manifester on le voit proposer une
loi sur le lait les sorties scolaires et
le voile etc des signes cdd en cdd
espèce de message qu'il envoie pour
regrouper un électorat qui est le plus
conservateur de la droite et qui me
semble être celui que travail d'autres
partis et je lui demande
elles paraissent une stratégie quelle
partie oui bon d'accord tous les cas là
par l'internet semble plus à des signes
politiques démagogues vers une une
droite extrait miser avec des timbres la
parole intérêt est fait pour faire de la
deûle écume et je ne trouve que c'est
dangereux parce que sur tous ces thèmes
il faut absolument arrêter la démagogie
répondre à david assouline
il n'y a pas de problème david assouline
et de gauche
il lui reste à fait bien
ss très mist de vouloir condamner ceux
qui pourrissent les manifestations n'ont
pas lu dégénérer les manifestations en
se masquant les black box oui j'ai fait
voter une loi au sénat que le
gouvernement
ensuite a repris pour condamner ceux qui
viennent avec des masses dans les
manifestations et j'en suis fier parce
que l'ordre doit régner et les
manifestations doit pouvoir se faire
pacifiquement
deuxièmement oui j'ai fait voter au
sénat une loi pour la laïcité pour faire
en sorte que les accompagnatrices qui
accompagnent les enfants dans les
sorties scolaires qui sont les
prolongements de l'école puisse le faire
son signe ostentatoire parce que je
considère qu'il faut protéger des jeunes
consciences c'est un nouveau combat pour
voir la laïcité
je pense que le communautaire s'il était
le même connu pour plutôt être un des
porte-voix de des mouvements comme sens
commun laisse nos nouveaux laissez moi
laissez vous n'avez tout maintenant moi
je ne confonds rien je la voulais imiter
politique loi de 2004 par exemple sur le
voile
c'est à dire à nicole c'est à dire
qu'elle a été postée été et c'est une
réussite
et bien moi j'ai prolongé je pense que
les sorties scolaires c'est l'école du
essayer de chaud dans quelques
communautés équipe d'affidés score
fracturée david assouline la laïcité
pour moi une autre jour combattu pour la
laïcité l'écouter c'est faux la combat
c'est vraiment voilà donc ces routes
comme le times par exemple sauvage le
camp si l'air de droit le combat là vers
la laïcité ce n'est pas des passe droits
ou des accommodements ou des
compréhensions pour une religion
majoritaire par rapport aux religions à
l'heure et bruno fahy cité pour toulouse
et notamment ceux et ben moi j'ai pas
envie que y ait des bonnes soeurs encore
net qui accompagnent les sorties
scolaires mais cher david assouline non
mais ça la laïcité elle s'est servie de
tous suite au no way non bien non alors
vous mener le combat par exemple avec
sens commun coûte la paix mais on s'est
très bien quels sont les réseaux et mais
les raisons revue
chivu relève fait d'être homosexuel
c'était la même chose vous allez
catholique s'est toujours défendu que
ceux menés là c'est par ici le robot
vous n'avez rien appris vous n'avez rien
compris et après on passait jamais
personne n'est pas l'absence pour les
uns les autres quand on est citoyen
d'avoir une foi et de la pratique et ça
n'est pas ça augmentant d'une laïcité
bien doit garantir la coexistence de foi
différente ou même de pensée
philosophique qui ne sont pas de l'ordre
de la fois c'est çà et là vous des
jeunes est passé à lorsque ça alors
c'est que j'ai fait depuis mai c'est
vous qui avez juste à meaux un mot pour
qui ait pas de malentendu sur la
question de la liberté de manifester
bien entendu que je suis contre ceux qui
cassent faisaient ouverte et non mais je
le prouve mais dans vos lois vous
restreignez par exemple on sait ensemble
opposé à une loi parce que sous couvert
de la loi ou d'une coup d'une cause
juste qui était de lutter contre la
haine sur le net
il y avait une restriction de la liberté
d'expression de la même façon vous avez
proposé une loi qui restreignait le
droit de manifester j'aurais rêvé de
l'émission s'est achevée vers vie qui
est là sur la loi vient chez vous dire
j'étais fier que mon groupe
justement soit le seul groupe c'est pas
la gauche qui a déféré la loi avia
auprès des conseillers la censure aux
gars femmes c'est à dire une
privatisation la censure de notre
liberté d'expression la zone est bien
bien bien sûr sauf que au bout du compte
qui a eu le courage d'aller voir le
conseil conscio neil de saisir le
consensuel qu'on sionnel qui a censuré
cette fois c'est le groupe et l'ère du
sans s'arrêter pour cette question hervé
berville voulait évoquer d'autres
contradictions de la part de bruno
retailleau notamment sur le plan de
relance européen
oui alors on est ont tous les pays
européens la france nos territoires vise
une crise avec une crise sanitaire et ce
qui se profile aussi devant nous vous le
savez tous bien c'est la question de la
crise économique et sociale
on doit tous lutter pour faire en sorte
à la fois de répondre aux urgences c'est
pour ça qu'on a mis en oeuvre on a voté
ce plan d'urgence à hauteur de 450
milliards d'euros et quand on se compare
aux autres pays on est paré dit
loin de là on a un plan ambitieux à la
fois pour les commerçants pour les
collectivités plus 4,5 milliards d'euros
pour les collectivités et à côté de ça
puisqu'on sait très bien que les défis
actuels ne pourront être résolus que
aussi au niveau européen international
et qui a une aspiration d'ailleurs de
nos concitoyens français d'avoir une
réponse européenne une coopération
période le président de la république
avec la chancelière angela merkel ont
proposé vous le savez 750 milliards
d'euros un plan de relance massif
ambitieux avec une forte aussi
coloration écologistes et moi la
question que je me pose
puis c'est que vous posez à bruno
retailleau dont oui bien évidemment
c'est que au fond je me demande ça ne
posait prostate mettra des années à
venir
ça va venir la question que je me pose
c'est au fond quel républicain êtes vous
ou alors qui sont les républicains
puisque au parlement européen
françois-xavier bellamy est totalement
contre ce plan de relance en disant
qu'on va faire de l'endettement alors
qu'à l'assemblée nationale actuellement
les républicains chez vous propose de
créer encore plus de dettes parce qu'ils
considèrent que le plan de relance qu'on
propose n'est pas assez ambitieux et au
sénat j'ai du mal à voir où est ce que
vous positionnez donc ma question elle
est très simple ce sont ces achats des
républicains nous un républicain anti
européen comme il peut y en avoir
certains dans votre mouvement à
bruxelles où un républicain qui ne veut
pas créer de l'endettement et qui du
coup ne veux pas répondre
alors je vous laisse répondre et en les
visionnant ça va très vite le sorte une
question qui a compliqué parce que vous
sur plusieurs niveaux de nous on a eu
une seule ligne
voyez notamment que nous avons exprimé
au sénat sur chaque au sénat sur chaque
paie les faire quand on a eu des
collectifs budgétaires nous avons
toujours accompagné le gouvernement
parce que nous pensions non pas que nous
sommes pas dans l'opposition mais nous
pensions que nous avions le devoir de
donner aux prisons de république et au
chef du gouvernement le premier ministre
les outils pour protéger les français
parce que la crise et sera profonde et
sera tellement profond d'ailleurs que
nous savons depuis la semaine dernière
il ya quinze jours par l' ocde et le fmi
que la france aurait sans doute la pire
des recettes des récession au niveau
mondial dans le monde développé
alors c'est vrai que françois-xavier
bellamy et donc mon but est vraiment
tout à fait d'accord sur un plan de
relance européen
mais nous nous ne voulons pas d'impôts
européens et c'est pas d'avoir peur il
ya une sujet vous êtes la vie
bien malin et aux dépens de l'allemand
ou reconnaît il ya eu des déclarations
aux européens
c'est une marche vers le fédéralisme et
nous y sommes opposés et nous pensons
qu'on a tellement d'impôts en france
qu'on n'a pas besoin en plus d'un nouvel
impôt européen et jours fériés de secret
défense
il n'y a pas mille ans rui alberto euro
perd mais je pense voyez que la
solidarité européenne
elle doit s'accompagner d'une
responsabilité et pourquoi les pays dits
frugaux on sait très six ans c'est parce
qu'ils se disent mais très bien nous on
a fait des efforts on travaille juste
par exemple pour la retraite à 65 ans à
67 ans et d'autres pays qui veulent
notre solidarité veulent rester avec des
âges de la retraite de 62 ans
donc avec les 35 heures c'est là le
problème la solidarité européenne
il faudra oui la solidarité mais à un
moment donné il faudra la responsabilité
de chacun vis-à-vis de tout ce que vous
n'êtes pas d'accord avec françois xavier
c'est noté merci david assouline merci à
riber binaire d'avoir animé ce débat
c'était très intense sovar sait pas
toujours le cas mais ce soir ça de l'été
particulièrement et on va rejoindre
vincent roux en direct du figaro live
vincent vous regardez un peu ce qui se
passe sur les réseaux sociaux il ya une
question qui va directement s'adresser à
bruno retailleau
oui parmi les articles les plus lus sur
le site du figaro course par bruno
retailleau cet article sur la défaite de
trois ministres et hier soir agnès
pannier rue nash et marlène schiappa à
paris et gabriel attal à vendre alors
parmi les commentaires il y à cet
internaute qui qui nous dit tous les
ministres battus doivent démissionner et
vous qu'en pensez-vous bruno retailleau
à moi vous savez c'est pas moi qui est
la clé de leur maintien ou leur
démission c'est le président de
république mais je trouve que quand un
ministre s'engage dans une élection
c'est mieux qu'il en tire lui-même les
conséquences mais en réalité pour moi
c'est de l'ordre du casting mais tout ça
je pense que avec l macron de toute
façon quelles que soient les hommes ou
les femmes c'est lui qui est à la
manoeuvre
merci vincent et yves thréard qui était
organiste au figaro nous a rejoints pour
pousuivre poursuivre le débat avec vous
arrive
bonsoir francis brand bonsoir bruno
retailleau en soi reste rare
à quelques questions vous avez beaucoup
parlé au début je crois de la suie sur
de la sphère fillon vous avez eu des
mots très durs contre le parquet le
parquet financier national financiers
dont nous a demandé la suppression mais
le jugement qui est intervenue ce sont
les juges du siège ce sont des juges
indépendants
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
indiqué que dans les 168 pages aucune
mention n'a été faite de la demande des
avocats de rouvrir les débats
c'est incroyable alors que la france
entière s'est ému des révélations du
chef du parquet national financier qui
avait indiqué jusque là bien sûr mais on
leur demandait pas de contredire tel ou
tel juge du parquet on leur demandait
simplement de donner droit et de rouvrir
les débats et même s'être ouverture des
débats
ils ne l'ont pas fait alors parce qu'il
ya une forme de corporatisme peut-être
d'accord il ya un corporatisme et il
faut interdire les syndicats dans la
magistrature
je pense que c'est pas sain en tout cas
on a une magistrature une partie cas
toujours été politisée regardez par
exemple le mur dès qu'on s'est
déclenchée à quelque chose incroyable
vous en savez quelque chose d ministre
d'intérieur en savent quelque chose
et pire des pères de victimes en savent
quelque chose quelles sanctions y at il
eu disciplinaire j'entends alors que le
jugement l'attitude du parquet vous
estimez que c'est grave on peut le
considérer
mais ça n'est pas moi qui n'ai je le
considère et c'est madame ou là qui
était madame ou la wii c'était la
patronne du pnl gens parfaits nationale
de répression
prenons raid et même des demandes
d'information était d'une pré scénario
stupéfiante
on peut considérer que c'est grave
d'autres peut-être le considère - est-ce
que ce qu'a fait françois fillon c'est
grave ce n'est pas à moi de le juger
ce n'est pas à moi de juger ce que je
dis moi c'est que il s'est trouvé une
élection présidentielle d'après le
dossier sénat millions un peu plus d'un
million d'euros qui aurait été détourné
mais tout était mais en quelques années
toutes été menée à charge et 1,1 un
tribunal un jugement
c'est une première instance c'est un
appel etc et on est au tout début donc
ce que je demande moi c'est que on
condamne pas françois fillon parce qu'il
faut le condamner la crainte c'est un
bouc émissaire un peu dans la sphère en
tout cas ma crainte depuis le départ
c'est que la justice était allé
tellement loin en faussant la démocratie
puisque ceux et celles qui ont voulu
intervenir en faisant en sorte qu'il
fallait absolument hâter les poursuites
pour le mettre en examen avant
l'élection présidentielle
quelques jours même d'ailleurs du dépôt
vous savez des candidatures non pas dix
candidatures mais par l'âge des
parrainages des mères c'est d'une
exceptionnelle gravité
c'est simplement ce que je souligne avec
jour était pas quand même qu'on coupe le
cordon ombilical entre la chancellerie
et le parquet général pour avoir un
attorney général exemple comme dans le
coeur de l'action moi je pense oui pour
avoir des shérifs voilà bah oui bah moi
je pense que c'est pas la tradition
prend c'est là que je pense qu on peut
en discuter j'ai répondu longuement sur
le recrutement sur le déroulement de
carrière et sur la responsabilité je
pense qu' aucun corps en france ne
saurait être à l'abri de sa propre
responsabilité
alors dans votre camp vous avez une voix
singulière et vous ont dérobé rarement
les élections municipales la ont montré
quelque chose d'assez étonnant notamment
à perpignan avec monsieur aliot qui a
gagné une grande ville au dépend
d'ailleurs d'un élu et l'air et il s'est
bien gardé de mettre en avant son
étiquette et l'air il a adopté la
jurisprudence
robert ménard nantes et rennes vous
aviez le radon est reine il a adopté la
jurisprudence robert louis louis aliot
d'eau pour reprendre prévoyez donc
espèce de droite on a appelé un moment
hors les murs mais une droite qui mord
sur le rn mais qui peut mortes sur les
républicains aussi ça ne vous inquiète
pas ça dans ce qui m'inquiète c'est que
j'ai de plus en plus d'élus la droite
qui est in veulent surtout pas
appartenir à quelques étiquettes que ce
soit pas plus qu'ils lui rendent elle ne
fait le printemps l'élection de louis
aliot à perpignan ne peut déterminer du
paysage politique français
c'est une évidence parce qu'il ya une
conjonction d'éléments avec un maire qui
était quelque peu fatigué voilà il n'y a
pas eu de renouvellement c'était un bon
maire
mais il était fatigué et un candidat qui
a fait oublier sa provenance qui sait
des rn 10 et j'invente j'avance de terre
est à front républicain qui n'a pas
marché et un front m mais parce que le
fonds répète parce que les électeurs
aujourd'hui sont totalement rétif aux
consignes nationales de d'autres ça
vienne tout que ça vienne
ils n'obéissent plus au conseil national
vous êtes partisan de primaires à droite
d'abord de quel droit tu du seul parti
les républicains ou plus large parce qu
on imagine que monsieur philippe quitte
le gouvernement ça peut arriver mais
pourrait se présenter plus large plus il
pourrait se présenter à cette primaire
est une crème et sur edouard philippe
par exemple une qui du gouvernement une
primaire ouverte ça n'a d'intérêt que si
puisque c'est ouvert on puisse
accueillir des candidatures internes à
l'air et externat mais alors edouard
philippe wahl viendrait dans une
primaire ouverte je suis pas sûr que ils
le souhaitent voyez pas mais ça fait
toujours un cirque il le souhaite est-ce
que vous pour vous même pour vous mais
pour moi même oui vous le souhaitez et
primaire oui vous iriez j'y réfléchirai
à deux fois non plus tôt c'est du tout
cuit non cdg réfléchir moi je veux
porter des convictions j'ai une commande
j'ai une conception de la droite voyez
parce que je vois bien certains noms
qu'est la famille celle de christian
secondes par exemple qui font du
marketing politique qui voudrait par
exemple une droite sociale une droite
libérale une droite régaliennes p je
veux une droite écoles jeu que la droite
couvre l'ensemble de son chargement au
scénario logique
je pense que on ne doit pas vendre à la
découpe la droite je pense que pour
répondre au défi des français il ya la
sécurité économique la sécurité
économique
croyez moi elle va être à l'ordre du
jour dès le mois d'octobre avec des gens
des centaines de millions de français
qui seront au chômage la sécurité
culturelle
la saison culturelle le discours d'une
écologie de droite qui souhaite une
écologie du bon sens avec des solutions
concrètes je pense que c'était cette
droite là on peut l'incarner il faut
l'incarner dernière question que c'est
une réponse
une dernière question de vivre c'est sa
dernière chance et y est ce que vous
pourriez et bien concourir si vos petits
camarades sont pas d'accord avec vous il
y en a qui sont pas d'accord avec vous
pour les prix perdent
est ce que vous pourriez y aller tout
seul vous voulez dire en dehors des en
dehors de la primaire ah non attendez si
vous avez une règle qui soit ouverte à
tous ont apprécié les réformes et si le
parent qui l'observé je suis un homme
d'engagement
et aussi un homme qui respecte sa part
vous avez votre propre parti
si vous si ya pas de primaire est ce que
vous pourriez y aller parce que si le
choix du candidat ou de la candidate ne
vous plaît pas est ce que vous pourriez
concourir j'exclus que l air puisse dans
un entre soi désigner un candidat de par
une procédure qui concernait radulov
quoi 10 non mais ça y est c'est
quelqu'un se détache ça c'est très
différent
on en discutera moi je veux pas être un
facteur de division dans ma propre
famille mais j'ai des convictions et je
les porterai si d'autres ne porte pas
ses jantes orient compte genthod que la
parole ne soit pas retiré à nos
militants et aux français sympathisants
qui ont cette sensibilité de la droite
par exemple est ce que vous le mauvais
est-ce que vous appréciez que nicolas
sarkozy finalement soit toujours le plus
populaire dans votre camp non mais la
popularité ça signifie rien d'autre même
pour sarkozy non mais dans un président
de république qui a retiré du pouvoir
il est populaire point final voilà c'est
systématique c'est une règle c'est pas
pour ça qu est-ce qu genre c'est parce
que les gens les gens critiquent bas
parce que les gens critiquent les
responsables petites qui sont au pouvoir
quand il quitte c'est pas un recours en
recours pour votre très bien ça c'est
pas un recours pour 2022 ans mais je
pense qu'il faut que la droite se
réinvente
on peut pas regarder l'avenir avec un
rétroviseur et sarkozy c'est le
rétroviseur
non mais ça il est comme sarkozy a été
un bon président de la république mais
je veux dire qu' il peut pas demain bon
candidat pour l'avenir de la droite
parce que voilà je pense que il a eu si
j'ose dire une période où il a dirigé
d'ailleurs la france et l'europe dans
une période très compliquée et il l'a
fait avec brio mais son temps est passé
mais attendez mais si la droite est
totalement figée sur le passé et c'est
terminé d'escale et sionisme en tournée
on n'a plus le temps non c'est sûr que
nous on n'a plus le temps risque
merci parce que oui le débat sur le
débat oui mais on a pu entendre mais on
savait que la sécurité qu on va pas leur
faute et on va relever à suivre
l'audition publique et merci à vous par
bruno retailleau invité alors oui on
continuera c'est la fin d'audition
publique bruno thériault merci d'avoir
accepté de répondre à nos questions d'
avoir débattu aussi et auditions
publiques revient à l'adie en direct à
19h bonne soirée
[Musique]